elle était ingénieur diplômé en langues
étrangères y politicienne et vrigne
khalaf prônait le dialogue une société
pluraliste avec huit autres personnes
dont son chauffeur
elle aurait été sommairement exécutés
samedi par les milices syrienne à la
solde de l'armée turque erdogan le
fasciste a tenu leurs mains dit sa mère
il a orchestré cette embuscade sauvage
contre l'humanité et wrynn est le
troisième enfant que perçoit de mohamed
au combat à différentes époques pour le
projet kurde et elle se dit prête en
perdre encore au delà d'un deuil
partager la cérémonie se veut un vibrant
appel à la résistance
les kurdes de syrie dit on ici ont déjà
sacrifié plus de dix mille fils et
filles pour lutter contre le groupe armé
islamique
ils peuvent mais encore d'en sacrifier
10000 pour qu'un seul cure puissent
vivre en liberté
une défiance réconfortante mais que les
derniers développements sur le terrain
trahissent les forces démocratiques
syriennes composé majoritairement des
unités de protection du peuple kurde ont
annoncé avoir revu leurs alliances
forcées distille par un repli des
troupes américaines et l'absence de
gestes concrets qui accompagnent les
condamnations fermes des pays européens
cette offensive prend le risque d'une
part de créer des situations
humanitaires insoutenable et d'autre
part d'aider dèche a réémergé dans la
région incapable de résister à la
puissance militaire turque ils ont passé
une entente avec le régime syrien dont
il été affranchie pour qu'ils se
déploient à la frontière ce n'est pas
assez ses condamnations dit le
responsable des relations
internationales
la guerre ne s'arrête pas trente a donné
son feu vert
si au moins il imposait une zone
d'exclusion aérienne s'il arrêtait les
avions de combat c'est rome qui leur a
donné cette capacité d' anéantir notre
peuple
avec ce retour en force de damas et ses
alliés russes dans le nord de la syrie
c'est une autonomie durement gagnés à
laquelle renonce les forces
démocratiques syriennes
mais le territoire leur fils entre les
mains à mesure des victoires de l'armée
turque et de leurs supplétifs syrien et
le sang des combattants comme des civils
a déjà trop coulé dans la journée un
convoi de civils venus manifester à
rastan avec une escorte militaire contre
la guerre déclarée par le président
erdan est tombé sous les tirs ennemis
ces images filmées par une équipe de
france 2 qui accompagnait la procession
témoigne du lourd bilan de cette attaque
dont les circonstances demeurent
nébuleuses au moins 11 morts civils dont
des journalistes à qamichli nous
retrouvons merde jeanne elle y était
pour soutenir les soldats qui luttent
contre ce qu'elle qualifie d' invasion
tout aussi terroriste que celle de dèche
elle était dans la rue quand est
survenue une explosion dit elle qui a
soufflé la vitre d'un commerce et l'a
projeté au sol j'ai vu beaucoup de
civils des blessés des brûlés des morts
c'était un massacre je n'arrivais pas à
savoir combien ils étaient je n'arrivais
pas à comprendre où j'étais blessée mais
elle ne regrette pas elle se ferait
martyrs pour le kurdistan
les martyrs ne meurent jamais disent les
chants des pleureuses
ils font désormais corps avec cette
terre pour laquelle ils ont tout
sacrifié ici marie-eve bédard radio
canada dans le nord de la syrie